hello everyone and welcome to a truly
incredible game app from 1935 it's the
mosque of Pioneer Home championship and
it's a game between an unknown person
and a vasilis missile former world
champion vasilis Mislov he was not world
champion at the time as the game was
played in 1935 and he became a world
champion in 1957 if you remember he has
referred to as one of the two so-called
winter Kings uh the other one being
Mikhail tal they've taken the World
Chess Championship title away from both
clinic but only for for one short winter
uh hence the two winter Kings before
about winning won it back but that's all
in the future this is uh the first game
Smith of played that was published in
the newspapers because it was so
incredible uh one of the problem is that
once it was published it was published
as as if Smith was playing wide and it's
a brilliancy with the black pieces so
that makes it a little bit sad but that
made it even more famous so getting back
to the game uh it's a fairly strong I
mean theoretically and well tactically
it will just blow your mind so let's
check it out here uh like I said an
unknown person that's why I'm wearing a
hoodie hope you guys are wearing a
hoodie as well uh it seems to be a
Czechoslovakian uh player called quresh
milk rashimov but I'm not certain of
that so I just put it as I found it
with the white pieces opens with Pawn to
D4 uh here uh we have appointed the five
Bice missile of Knight to F3 Knight to
F6 and now uh Ponte E3 we have Ponte E6
and Bishop to D3 so the standard uh coal
system stuff and also some of the some
something you might remember if you've
been following the channel uh Boris
paski once uh was giving an interview
and he referred to uh vaselism as the
hand and after that the nickname kind of
stuck with him because he said that his
hand always goes for the correct piece
at the correct time and it's one of the
it's actually one of the coolest
nicknames in in the entire chess history
like uh maybe okay uh Joseph Henry
Blackburn was called the black death but
other than that I don't know I mean
there are some cool ones but the hand
that's a really an incredible nickname
and you will see why in this game uh
missile was 14 years old when he when he
played this game so here Pawn to C5
striking in the center we have B3 Knight
to C sorry Knight to C6 Bishop to beat
you and now Bishop to D6 all very
standard stuff that's played even today
we have Queen to C7 and A3 and this is
again a position you will see even in
today's games of modern Grand Masters
where E5 might be played C captures and
D for migroup play castles might be
played but here we have Pawn to B6 and
it is now as of move 8 that this
position has never been reached again uh
we have Pawn to C4 and nicely striking
against black center with Bishop to B7
and now Knight to C3 we have Pawn to A6
and and here Rook to E1 Ponte A6 was a
slight inaccuracy by Smith but um it's
not easy taking advantage of that I will
show it because it's super fun C
captures ecampers and now D captures on
C5 usually you don't want to just start
capturing in the center as they said to
take is a mistake but here it actually
works after Bishop captures just Knight
to the A4 and after the bishop moves
Rook to C1 and the white will have
an excellent game B5 is coming Knight
the D4 is coming and uh well y just has
a very strong game but okay uh they were
fairly young at the time we have rooked
the E1 uh and now comes C captures on D4
Smith is the one that gets the chance to
take first in the center he captures
with castles by Vasily and now Knight to
A4 opening up the dark Square Bishop uh
we have Bishop to F4 uh and here uh
White should really consider just
playing positionally with Fanta C5 like
Pawn to C5 you're threatening uh the
Capron B6 and after captors you just get
a beautiful C5 Outpost for your knight
and everything is perfectly fine however
here white probably wanted to open up
the The Bishop's diagonal or or
something he played Knight to the E5 and
here as missiles kind of uh just comes
back into the game d captures on C4 B
captures on C4 and now Knight captures
on E5 we have d-captress attacking the
Knight here and this will win in the E4
Square for white however Smith throws a
nice situation sug in and that is Queen
to C6 he is now threatening Checkmate
and you don't have time to capture the
knight uh and you don't uh if the Knight
moves then the E4 Square would be
claimed by the bishop so this is a great
in between move by Smith so here after
Queen to C6 we have Bishop to F1 and
this seems like a much more classy move
than F3 F3 looks like uh something a
barbarian might play but it's actually
the correct way to play the problem with
Bishop to F1 as you'll see later is that
the bishop will be overloaded even
though okay it's defending the G2 Pawn
uh perfectly fine uh Rook F to d8 by
Smith going after agrashimov's Queen
here Queen to B3 here last opportunity
for whites to stay in the game is to go
for this worse end game Queen to F3
captures captures and now the game
continues nothing special knight D7 F3
is hanging E5 is attacked I mean not not
the best but instead Queen to B3 was
played and now look at what's Miss love
comes up with this is an absolute a
brilliancy knight the G4 now threatening
to capture on H2 Ponta H3 and of course
when when in chess history something
good happened when white played Pawn to
H3 so feel free to pause the video and
win the game for Smith's love in great
style while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on spotting this uh
well absolute brilliancy and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Rook to D3 that's what Smith
played and now there's really nothing
you can do okay you could start with
Bishop to H2 check so congratulations to
everyone who found that as well uh but
you should always uh start with
something other than check if you're
somewhere in a bar or in a library and
you're showing your friends something
you never want to start with the check
that will not impress them you have to
start with the move that that does not
uh come with check so Rook to D3 and now
how do you reply the bishop cannot
capture The Rook because the bishop is
now stuck guarding the G2 Pawn like I've
mentioned uh if you capture The Rook
with the queen look at this queen
captures Bishop to HD check or now
Knight captures and F2 is is a terrible
threat King h1i characters on F2 will
win the White Queen so that's out of the
question so after Rook to D3 girashimov
said all right that's uh that I've had
enough of this let's just trade Queens
he played Queen captures on B6 but but
now Smith's lock shows the the real
intention behind Rook to D3 and that's
Rook captures on H3 we're gonna do this
one in slow motion there you go Rook
captures on H3 and now again you cannot
uh you cannot do anything that there's
just too much if you capture The Rook
then Queen captures and H1 is Checkmate
if you capture the queen queen captures
and C6 then just a nice Bishop to H2
check King H1 and the Knight captures an
F2 is Checkmate and uh since none of
this works in the game garage move
played dash of the D4 to keep an eye on
the F2 Pawn saying okay I'm gonna trade
Queens next uh but here as Miss love
just played Bishop to H to check King to
H1 and now Bishop captures an E5 with
check and he was in this position unmove
22 that are good friend K garashimov
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so uh here you see
why why is basket referred to uh
vaselism as the hand as his his hand
just picks up the right piece at the
right moment and here you resign because
now you are in check only movies King to
G1 but now look at this bishop page to
check and the E5 Pawn is now gone King
H1 and now the bishop can go all the way
back to C7 and win the White Queen
absolutely absolutely incredible uh King
to G1 Bishop capture Sun B6 and okay you
will regain some material but after Rook
H2 there's no defense against Rook
captures on G2 so truly truly a
remarkable uh game by by Smith a young
14 year old Smith in the mosque of
Pioneer Home Championship like I said
some uh 22 years
before he became world champion and uh
at the time this game was played uh as
this was played in November it's a very
interesting uh Alexander Aiken was still
world champion even though he lost his
title in 1935 to Max do that but that
was like a month after this game was
played so I actually I actually thought
that um this was played while uh uh Max
was world champion but it wasn't that he
was still world champion and then a
month after this game that you've took
his title and then of course uh Ali
regained it back but yeah now you've
seen it now you know why they why they
called him the hand and if you guys
enjoyed it we could check out some other
uh missile brilliances but if you have
some that you guys would enjoy for me to
cover always use hashtag suggestion in
the comments
uh that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it I would like to thank Anthony Moore
at hslr.com
Brown the third and Stefano Steinbach
for a contribution to my channel thank
you a lot I really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and I
will see you soon continuing to check up
on you wonderful suggestions and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day